Are you still using Opus 5.6? You are so
Last week, OpenAI just dropped GPT 5.4
and it's the best model ever created. Or
is it? We don't know. But I mean, no, we
know. We tried.
>> We will tell you.
>> We know. We know. We tried it all last
week and now we can we can say if it's
the best one.
>> We are going to show you.
>> Okay, cool. Nice. Okay, intro done.
>> Comparing 5.4 versus 4.6.
>> GBT 5.4 4 thinking and GPT 5.4 proof
rolling out now in chat GPT. GPT 5.4 is
also available in the API in N codeex.
Thank you. GPT 5.4 brings our advanced
reasoning coding and agentic workflow
into one frontier model aka we don't
have GPT codeex anymore. OS world
verified 75% codeex 5.3 and Opus 4.6 72.
It's better but it's not like I will
never use Opus 4.6 6 ever again because
5.4 for it that better, right? Why why
don't they call the models like this is
the best entropic best model one, best
model two? How was your week, man?
>> I was doing a lot and then then we had
the new version and everything went
again so much better.
>> It's really really good. Like I switched
to and I love finally open AI model.
>> Yeah, I I even switched back from using
cloud a lot to using codec much more
>> 1% I open once. So I have eight tabs and
sometime I open another tab to have more
pans where I open the in each and today
I had eight pans of products and I use
after a day of coding I use 10% of my
weekly reset which has been resetted
like three time this week. So thank you
for the bugs
>> and all eight screens are just ongoing.
>> What I do is I have the background task
inside the codeex cli. So Codex is
listening to the processes and if there
is a react issue on the background like
a root root issue or like missing a file
whatever then it get intercepted right
away by the CLI and fix it right away.
>> Okay. So it's like a listener.
>> Yeah, exactly. I run the apps directly
from that and it's making way less
mistakes. Even like on animations of
like I had some issues with like size
bar animation stuff was completely
[__] up and Codex like did a really
good job with like animation of the
pants you know collapse collapse the
sidebar and stuff like that. So Genfeit
is the best app I ever built
>> and it's getting better and better as
the AIS get better.
>> Yeah. What what about you man?
>> I was just building everything with
cloud and for example my my Zenesk
rebuild for my own ticket system. I had
some issues when I add a CC to an email
or to a ticket and cloud said it was not
completely possible as I requested to
show it in the normal email sending way.
It had to do something different and I
just tried it several times and I had a
second issue where it was saying that I
could not easily put images in line. I
had to do everything through attachment
and I did I didn't check it myself.
Cloud did everything. But no, I asked
Codex 5.4 before and within 10 minutes
both problems were solved and I tried it
multiple times with Opus 4.6.
>> What about 5.3?
>> I didn't because 4.6 was better than
5.3.
>> Okay. What about like planification? Do
you still plan with clothes review with
codeex or you do switch it?
>> Yeah, I used to do at 5.3 in codeex and
4.6 Sex Opus used to ask both of them to
create the same plan and just merge it
and then have one of the two build it.
But right now, Opus is doing like 15
minutes on a plan to 20 minutes when
it's a big one. Research online stuff.
And then Codex 5.4 did it in 2 minutes.
>> It's way faster.
>> And they have the the fast mode where
you burn double tokens. I didn't even
enable it. I saw a tweet from Peter
levels.io, you know,
>> and he said, "For the first time in my
my life for like for the last for the
first time in the last 15 years, my
dashboard is empty." Even for genfit I
would like people to open PR directly in
GitHub have the user entering on GitHub
and whatever and create just the issue
and then you assign the agent and then
that's it. It makes sense to be a
project manager spending it uh your time
in in the board.
>> I've been doing the 5.4 for now for a
few days
and everything that was sitting on the
bench like this is going to take some
extra research or whatever
>> or I have to do a better plan mode
everything is fixed I even switched my
open claw to 5.4 and the the discord
quality of the med messages
>> it went up a lot
>> 5.4 4 has a 1 million context window and
op.
>> Yeah, but there is a difference. Op has
a maximum context window of 1 million
tokens, but by default it's 200k unless
the 1 million context feature is enabled
through the API beta flag. So you can
use the 1 million, but only the true
devs who set up the the initial uh setup
and they make changes, they can get to
the 1 million.
By default, it has 200K. Yeah. But it's
the same thing for the the codeex 5.4.
It says 1 million.
>> It is by default on the API. And if you
do the CLI, you have to change the
settings.
>> Yeah. But like if you if you have a two
like if the context is too big, then the
output is way cheaper, right? [laughter]
5.4 the best model or no.
>> Yes. At this moment, it for sure is.
>> Until next week.
>> Until next week. [laughter]
But yeah, man. Michelle, thank you so
much for your time.
>> Yes, thank you.
>> Yes. And uh yeah, bye everyone. Bye.
>> Have a good evening. You too.